all right let's begin this hour with
coverage of the countdown to election
day now under three weeks away we are
taking our three meals series back on
the road to break bread with voters in
key States and hear what's on their
minds first stop Arizona with its three
hotly contested Statewide races and each
of them the Republican Contender
including those who run the state's next
elections back the falsehood that former
president Trump won in 2020. Ed O'Keefe
took a road trip through Arizona and hit
three different restaurants for his
three meals
foreign
[Music]
Gulf in the Grand Canyon State we
started our day at Harlow's Cafe Tempe
Arizona institution
owned by the essence since 1980. this
place has happened
[Music]
regulars fuel up on breakfast favorites
coffee just like my third house and
occasionally something even stronger
what's your favorite item on the menu
Bloody Mary Bloody Mary well those are
pretty good that's friends Jeff and
Brian's politics also bleed red I think
Joe Biden's worst president ever man why
uh first of all look at gas that caught
me the Border we got fentanyl he doesn't
care about it he doesn't care about
Americans don't we'd run again all you
have to do is say all right are you
better off now than you were four years
ago when I was in office and the answer
would be a resounding no hello Phoenix
former president Trump endorsed
Republican Blake Masters to unseat
Arizona Senator Mark Kelly a Democrat
Mark Kelly does nothing for the state
what do you know about Blake Masters I
don't know anything about it he's just
not Mark Kelly
okay he's indoors by Trump I'm good with
that yeah
I think does it make it easier jump into
my bedding for me Trump can do your
vending yeah yeah
like them I'm gonna like them Karen
Kellogg agrees on Harlow's Bloody Marys
but the State's new near total ban on
abortion it's scary as a 22 year old
finally ready to register to vote here I
thought that my government has failed me
I thought that this system no longer
works for its people Shirley and Samuels
coffee is good on her way to the Grand
Canyon shares Karen's concerns the
abortion that's a big issue for me
because I thought we were going past
that that's unbelievable that we're here
now what do you think of the president
how do work to be done from there we
headed east on Highway 60 leaving behind
all the sprawl Maricopa County which
includes Phoenix added more new
residents last year than any other
County in the country it's gotten so big
here that they had to redraw the
Congressional lines in a way that made
about three or four of the districts far
more competitive than they would have
been in the past
one of those districts is here in Copper
mining country where we found more signs
of the election
and in Superior Los Hermanos run by
these Dos Hermanos Anthony and Richard
and so you were two of the original six
brothers he's in
owner Richard Cameron's team still makes
the tortillas by hand but not like they
used to we used to go through about 400
pounds of flour a day
five and six days a week now we go 100
pounds four days a week still talk of
politics sizzles
like their signature chimichangas if one
of those candidates walked in here right
now to have lunch what would you say to
them get rid of all the Bulls the Trump
what do you mean by that well you know
what I mean you see it on TV all the
time it's all of them you know I can't
trust the Democrat and I'm a Democrat
you know because you put them in
Washington they do the same thing
Russell kichner a registered independent
here with his wife Lorraine saw that in
President Biden's decision to forgive
some student loans I got student loans
my wife got student loans millions of
people got student loans then we paid
them back that's strictly a case of
catering to a population that already
leans toward his party
so you know I see through that and I
hope he pays for it
politically I hope he does
for dinner we drove South towards the
Border and El Charro Cafe in Tucson
celebrating its 100th birthday
[Music]
the country's oldest family-owned
Mexican restaurant
90 year old Barbara Madison has been
around almost as long I'm a Democrat so
I'm voting for the Democrats
although we've had some pretty good
Republicans in this state Sean McCain
Barry Goldwater I mean he's been around
his office very cold everybody so
just a table away you have a preferred
candidate I do but I won't tell you who
it is
Danielle Taylor didn't hold back on her
top issues securing our borders first
and foremost nothing's more important to
me than securing our borders and I am a
small business owner and so keeping in
mind that the inflation is a real
problem for the mom making this election
personal how personal do you want me to
be it's up to you
I would like to see this country turn
around for the better and voting is the
only way to make that happen
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was a lot to digest if you will but
one thing we kept hearing over and over
again from people we met with is they
basically just want their elected
leaders to hear them to understand that
there's a lot of pain and concern and
confusion out there and they want people
all the way here in Washington we're
there in Phoenix to do something about
it to do something about it uh let's
call out these places again Harlow's
Cafe in Tempe Los Hermanos and Superior
and El Charro Cafe they've got a few
spots in Tucson all of them gracious to
open their doors the customers gracious
with their time guys if I never see
chips and salsa again that would be a
good thing we were served it at dinner
we were served it at lunch we were even
served chips and salsa at breakfast they
were very good but yeah I'm good for a
while it was a great piece let me tell
you though that that French toasted
Harlow's it's a perfect shade of gold
and brown and fluffy and thick although
there was a lot of substance to your
peas I'm still thinking about that
French toast but what I really like is
how candid people yeah candid people are
with you because talking politics is
always such a personal thing but it
shows you how frustrated people are and
they want their voices heard and you
gave them that well Gail you know yeah
and he Ed's a veteran and he knew he
would get good uh comments from the guys
drinking the Bloody Marys in the morning
but those guys were really interesting
but Brian told you uh at about if
president former president Trump likes a
candidate then they like the candidate
that's essentially what the former
president is banking on when he endorses
certain candidates and when Charlene
told you that she thinks that we have a
lot more to do even though she voted for
President Biden but that was telling as
well Ed what are you thinking yeah it
was it was it was just incredible to see
so much of what we read about and
reading the polls personified by those
people it helps to have a drink and a
full belly when you're talking politics
it seems yeah all right it's a great
piece Ed really well done really really
well done thank you so much coming up